j'aimerais vraiment pour le clip des
téléspectateurs à 21h41 qu'on fasse une
séquence qui restera mythique je suis
sûr dans la télévision française
j'aimerais voir une minute de
discussions entre jean claude van damme
et doctrinale juste au moc et ouais on
va mettre à chrono ce côté de tout ce
que vous voulez qu'on voit là
franchement de la boîte aux lettres il
adore les sciences jean claude alors
attention voilà à l'etivaz une minute
vous discuté on oserait on dire nous
dira si j'ai des scientifiques
l'assureur science le sujet de départ je
vais commencer avec les choses frequency
les fréquences par exemple la fréquence
humain donc c'est à dire donc si je te
parle c'est 432 et jane et dans le
téléphone c'est 4 4 4 ce qui ne le
cancer d'ailleurs et ça a été a été créé
et inventé par adolf hitler pour la
propaganda non mais pendant la guerre
oui la seconde guerre mondiale c'est ça
il y à il y avait en entende on émettait
sur des fréquences et toutes ces
fréquences elles sont restées ça veut
dire que tu peux entendre encore des
gens dans l'avion entre énergie nb
attention et me fiscale
franchement je rajoute une minute alors
oui mais si à propos de fréquences
chaque specis animaux sur la terre bénie
spécisme ont des fréquences différentes
de communication ok donc il faut pas
oublier avec les affiches en italie
jones comme ils connaissent toutes les
fréquences du monde entier les gens qui
disent qu'un et quand peter ne sont pas
vivant et j'y crois pas tellement avec
un pétaflop est égal à 30 et a billion
de penser une seconde est des
compétiteurs qui font entre 75 pétaflops
à 125 comme ça où l'alcool pions mais je
sais j'en étais à millions d'équations x
175 pas la réponse
alors est-ce que qu'est ce qui pourrait
entraîner à natanya qu'est ce que vous
répondez pour un sage en jogging en fait
l'essai fréquences elles sont restées
dans l'air acquittez et vous pouvez tu
peut les entendre
elles sont c'est tout ce qu'ils ont émis
pendant cette période c'est resté comme
ça dans l'air ils veulent entendre
et grâce à quoi au plasma le placement
[Applaudissements]
cette fréquence
j'ai adoré jean claude jean cot et sont
très intelligents les deux eric
we can prononcée le gall m6 j'ai cru
qu'elle aborde mais j'ai eu de la chance
j'ai de la chance je vais très vite j'ai
vite
à 13 ans j'ai vendu des fleurs j'ai fait
un peu d'argent et puis j'ai fait une
salle de sport et puis movistar puis
hollywood canada pendant sept ans qu'est
ce que j'ai fait jour et nuit
tu m'as tube qui est l'éducation de
maintenant donc j'ai pas pris
adam f la pomme l'enfant donc j'ai
commencé dans les choses comme queen
century et les choses que les gens pour
l'instant m'ont pas aidé vue qui
travaillent et n'ont pas le temps de
voir et d'apprendre les choses
aujourd'hui que toi tu peux l'être il ya
eu cette exclusion ne connaissez vous
pas des noms mais les super intéressant
ouais c'est vrai
dans les deux îles à des duos
non mais il est super intéressant j'ai
cru ce soir